what if you have a filmmaking friend
that says you know what my husband's
mother in law is going to give us X
amount of dollars what's that
conversation you would have is that
right cuz husband's mine yeah someone
you're not related to has access to your
friend friends from college did really
well got out before the whole dot-com
crash raised on an island decides you
know what I want to invest in indie film
I want to not invest but I want I want
to help you i want to put money in d
movies right all that talk you would
have them have with that friend are
realistically it depends on it depends
on the person you're talking to and what
their friends sounds like I've had
conversations where they sell goes I
have someone who wants with money in
movies but they they're they're pro NRA
very political see it's make sure
there's guns in the film in some
positive way that's sort of the N would
conversation you know it's like all the
film was gonna end with a big explosion
but the film ends with this not anymore
also I got a nephew not a bright boy but
something tells me you'd be a lovely i
get these constraints on it the sort of
the best way to preface the conversation
i think is if someone knows someone who
has access to money or knows people who
have access to money is this say to that
person okay here's what I need I need
this much money here's the investment
agreement or whatever it is and you have
these people if you can get these people
to come in and sign the line which is
dotted and make this on the go film I'll
give you ten percent of the budget as
your fee and I'll make you an executive
producer you'll be executive producer
and when the cache hits our account and
clears the first check is going to be
used if we're raising two hundred
thousand dollars first text going to be
DQ for twenty thousand dollars for
finding the money and that's a good way
of approaching it because a lot of these
deals are done through social means I
mean film is about a smart financial
investment there's not a lot of return
you don't do it because it's going to
make money you do because it's fun
because it's cool you do it because you
like movies you do things like people
involved you believe in the dream you
you do it because you know that's no one
had invested in darren aronofsky or
Quentin Tarantino in the beginning we'd
have we wouldn't have black swan or Pulp
Fiction do it for those reasons so if he
takes it involves being that politician
again taking someone to dinner and
buying the drinks and saying the right
things and making sure you're fit and I
think there's only so much of a show you
want to put on and so many compromises
you want to make before it's silly but
if you have a buffer someone who knows
that person gets long and i'm already
their friends having them have an
incentive to get the deal done to maybe
take that dinner one with you one
without you and so it would be the
social buffer and stay in the situation
and help work it out and a bad way to go
and it's not dishonest because you know
it is you're beating us what you want we
want this money but this person is
involved in the process and they can
make a little coin off but it's not a
bad way to go
you